[Music]
all right A different kind of music at 6
17 on your Friday morning what's cool
it's cool how about 2 000 Clark County
School District fourth and fifth graders
seeing and hearing something most if not
all have never experienced an orchestra
concert
dollar
silver Knights hockey team had been
transformed
and before the concert started as
musicians were tuning up they mingled
with the students getting up close and
personal with trumpets piccolos violins
the piece I had the honor of narrating
the orchestra game it's all about having
fun while educating the students about
the different parts of an orchestra
[Music]
the woodwinds
we get to hear the strings
but the real magic happened when
conductor Alexander Aries brought a
student to the podium so how old are you
nine years old Mila was given a pair of
glasses a scarf and a baton that looked
a lot like a magic wand
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much Mila
uh how about that you know and it's not
just Mila who's going to remember the
day the narration in the orchestra games
lays it right out maybe some of the
students at the concert are going to
catch some of that magic and maybe end
up as a musician maybe even a conductor
all because they attended the Henderson
Symphonies concert for kids you know we
always want to know what's cool at
school you got something let us know
cool at school on the community tab of
her website or just email cool at school
at 8newsnow.com I cannot tell you how
much of an honor it is to be on stage
with those musicians with the conductor
and with those students out in the
audience one of the teachers even told
me not just the first Concert Experience
for at least one kid she said the kid
had never even been on a bus oh wow I
remember when I was a kid in doubt
growing up in Dallas and we did a few
Trip To The Music Hall at Fair Park and
and listen to the Dallas Symphony and it
was so exciting for it just what those
kids did and I will never forget that as
long as I live and then I went on to
play French horn and it made a huge
impression on me exactly so thanks again
for having me out there and good luck to
all the kids and send us more of your
coolest schools